well it's just like everybody who got
fired for not getting the vaccine at
work they they just went I'll get
another
job Long Live Texas and Florida man yeah
let's edit that out cuz our our W
audience isn't going
[Music]
to so Donald Trump has been found guilty
of and has to pay $83 million
for you got to say that in the first two
minutes oh [__] well they going to bleep
it out they're going to bleep it wait
he's this is new convicted why' you say
it like that what the that no that's the
head the headline readers that's what
they say he's reading verbatim What like
TMZ would say yeah the people who just
look on Twitter and they scroll that's
what they're saying right now is that is
that what where's the headline from uh
everywhere every everywhere is saying
that like this guy's a you now graper
Sor all and then and then what and then
what is
so the real story is this lady named EEG
Carol I'm sure you've heard of this
before ien actually you haven't okay so
she um basically sued Trump saying that
he defamed her because she accused him
of graping her in a part department
store 30 years ago the fitting room
thing right rushes her in there and like
and just starts going at it with her and
then and she says that he did that to
her 30 years ago um there's really not
evidence for it right there's no there's
no corroborating evidence for it shock
in fact they actually um there's a a
statute of limitations in New York where
they it's like hey you can't bring up
something that happened like C for a
certain amount of time oh except for
this year you can do it oh yeah they
changed it they changed it because
election year because that's what people
that's what the conspiracy the not
because of that that's what conspiracy
theorist say no they want Justice now
they decided that they made a big
mistake and it's time for justice yeah
just Justice now 365 days for justice
that's what they call it so um yeah so
you had a one-year window to reopen any
sort of old defamation cases oh this one
just so happened to come to life
convenient and then she she's just
successfully sued Trump for defaming her
character because she said hey you did
this and he says no I didn't and you're
lying so it's not because of the actual
it's because she accused him and the
reaction from the public has cost her
her reputation yeah so that's why the
headlines all a little that's why I open
with the headline that I did because
that's what everyone is saying all over
the place but it's not did he comment on
her accusation there was Zero admission
of guilt he just was like I don't even
didn't he say like he doesn't even know
her I don't know her but then they did
they did find a picture of him and her
yeah right and he says I think that's my
wife Mara or whatever right he didn't
even remember yeah he didn't remember I
imagine Trump's taking photos with quite
a few people over the decades that's
what people a lot of people were saying
the conspiracy theorists are saying that
yeah pulling up a photo with someone's
not exactly um right doesn't mean that
they did the thing I've been almost as
famous As Trump for the past couple of
years and I think like even I have
trouble remembering some of the photos I
took with the fans that that are sent to
me so I go wow how could you I can't
remember all so I'm assuming that maybe
it's difficult for Trump to remember
what you know we have somebody that can
identify with what an
empath but yeah he said his whole story
or her story was that she agreed to help
him go shopping or something and then in
the middle of that he like pushes her
into the fitting room starts
passionately kissing like she used to
work for him like no it was like a thing
they just met they just met each other
there's a lot of stuff with this so
there's apparently a Law and Order
episode that matches her story and
apparently she's a huge Law and Order
fan that's that's number one thing
that's wild so it's a plagiarized
there's another thing too where she
talked about wearing a certain kind of
dress that actually didn't exist until
several years after what she reported oh
like a certain fabric or something right
so she was perhaps fashion forward EX
exactly that's
great um there's there's a lot of and
she also went on Anderson Cooper we
talked about this a couple I think like
a year ago where she was on with
Anderson Cooper I don't know if you've
ever heard about this but she was with
Anderson Cooper she says grape is kind
of sexy if you think about it that's
what she said she said that on TV yeah
she did to Anderson Cooper and they
instantly cut to commercial like we'll
be
right that's insane yeah it was wild
dude so what so is Trump actually gonna
have to pay her no well he's going to
appeal okay but apparently you have to
you have to take a certain amount that's
like owed from this case put it into a
bond in order to appeal so he definitely
will have to lock up some funds to
appeal 83 dude yeah be able to it is
crazy election year and like the amount
of games that everyone's trying to play
that game is really interesting because
that window of time that they added so
that they could put that in just 12
months crazy to open up the statute
limitations for one year only and this
is the biggest case that went through 12
that's kind of tight though like these
games make it kind of fun sometimes
right the funny thing is I just imagine
other I just imagine other cases that
really happened and then these women
come forward they're like oh 12 months
and they try to file it and they go h n
I think we already we're good we got
enough yeah well is it about Trump do
you really want to do this not exactly
are you sure you want to do this was he
Orange No Yeah Yeah Yeah from an
international perspective does uh
America's president like who it is do
you does it do you guys feel the effects
like from internationally like like do
you guys have a person you guys root for
sometimes too yeah and um yeah generally
in most countries I mean the US For
Better or For Worse is the leader of the
Free World thing is not just a cliche it
is it is real I mean economically
culturally like politically in many ways
they say when the US sneezes the UK or
the world catches a cold and there's a
lot of Truth to that there's a lot of
Truth to that you can see where things
are going based on what's happening in
the states and the US is I mean America
here's something I learned just just
about 5 days ago do you know how many
foreign military bases the US has
outside the 500 five over okay over over
750 in 80 over 80 different countries
750 750 I knew it was a lot 750 in over
80 different countries well I just saw
we we have a base in Jordan I'm like we
have a Bas in Jord dude that's this is
how I that's exactly where I was like
why are they in Jordan um do you know
how many China has overseas five one
where is that one I think South Africa
they've done a really good job silencing
everybody you found out about there 700
and that's probably 750 we know about
like there's probably hell top secret
you know on dud black sights everywhere
yeah for the ones on
Zillow yeah it could be like every
McDonald around the world is actually us
CIA like freaking missile comes out of
the back yeah underneath that's bad what
a tactic wow what a collab 750 you know
a lot of Americans wonder why a lot of
um a lot of non-americans Care About Us
politics and what's going on and
whatever and it's kind of cuz us
politics cares about the rest of the
world like the US isn't it's crazy even
if you look at conflicts going on it's
like the US is always involved somehow
yeah we're the no yeah it's strange lady
this thing Happ you know Israel P like
us is there Ukraine Russia us is there
us is it's Jordan blew my mind I mean I
wasn't surprised ultimately cuz I've
heard from my brothers cuz they were
they were both in the military that that
we have [__] everywhere yeah all over
Africa why is the Jordan one so
mindblowing because we just talk about
it like it's normal like when when you
when you watch the news and they go um
this base was attacked in Jordan and we
just go we we're all just supposed to go
oh that's that's normal but we we don't
go like wait why are they in Jordan that
that's weird do we have a [__]
declaration of war against Jordan like
what what's up with that why do we have
that yeah that's that's exactly that
question is exactly what prompted me to
be like wait why are they there and then
I was like how many bases are there and
how many places and it was like went
down the rabbit yeah and they numb us to
it though they numb us to it so expertly
because we're just we're used to just
hearing like an American bass and then
the thing but like we don't go like wait
why is there an American base there
that's what blows my mind that's the
thing is you grow up just thinking
everywhere has American bases and then
you also assume it's transitive that
like oh then that means every other
country must have a base every
otherwhere else but yeah it's like a
foreign exchange
program must be a Chinese kid living
here it reminds me of what they did to
US during Co where they go hey the
government says you have to stay home
and you're just like all right my bad
yeah right it's not like wait don't I
have rights I'm not you're not supposed
to be able to tell me that but no people
go oh right yeah yeah thank you thank
you well it's just like everybody who
got fired for not getting the vaccine at
work they they just went I'll get
another
job Long Live Texas and Florida man yeah
let's edit that out cuz our our W
audience
isn't I think third biggest fan Bas is
from Texas dude our third biggest fan
base is the TSA
dude we have a h i don't know why has
everybody experienced that TSA every
airport yeah there's always someone to
recognize
on the international or that's
interesting that means our fans are very
blue collar they can't expedite us or
anything they're cool to the D this to
your
balls as they say I'm a fan of J yeah
I'm a fan of JK it's like great dude
okay use they use the back of that back
of the hand you yeah it's fine I love
how that's meant to make it better do
it's the back of my hand I've done that
to my wife's [__] plenty of
times get it divorce is happening and
then they go on our comments and say I
can confirm Steve's dick is pretty big
as a TSA agent
yeah I grazed it TSA agent here my bag
of the head felt a SCH I was going like
[Music]
that